See, the problem is we've added too many of them. Yep. That's why you got me, Bryce. I memorize all this stuff for fun. It makes me happy. See, there's this thing called Google that replaces you pretty well. I don't need Google because, I mean, don't get me wrong. I don't think about the set algorithms very often, like asymmetric difference or et cetera, those ones.
看吧，问题是我们加了太多这种东西。没错。这就是为什么你找了我，布莱斯。我为了好玩背下所有这些东西。这让我很开心。看，有个东西叫谷歌，它能很好地替代你。我不需要谷歌，因为，我的意思是，别误会我。我不常去想集合算法，比如非对称差集等等之类的。
But you know, these ones are, these ones are fundamental. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 115 recorded on February 1st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we discuss a problem entitled Max Gap and solve it in C++23. See if you can listen along and solve it yourself. So I will be coming to Toronto, not once, but twice, and not seeing you. What? to toronto not once but twice and not seeing you what because it this is apparently the the easiest routing for me to get upgrades to london on is is the la guardia to to toronto then toronto to um london on british airways it's it's this is my secret this. This is my secret. This is my secret. The LaGuardia
但你知道，这些是，这些是基础。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 115 期，录制于 2023 年 2 月 1 日。我是康纳，今天和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，我们讨论一个名为“最大间距”的问题，并用 C++23 解决它。看看你能否一边听一边自己解决它。所以我将要去多伦多，不是一次，而是两次，而且还见不到你。什么？去多伦多不是一次而是两次却见不到你？什么？因为这显然是让我转机去伦敦最简单的路线，就是从拉瓜迪亚飞多伦多，然后从多伦多飞……嗯，英国航空的伦敦航班，这就是，这就是我的秘密。这就是我的秘密。这就是我的秘密。拉瓜迪亚
to London by way of Canada special. I mean, you can come hang out with me at the airport. I can't. We already talked about this. Because you'll be in the International. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I'm going to be
经由加拿大去伦敦的特价航班。我的意思是，你可以来机场找我玩。我不能。我们已经讨论过这个了。因为你会国际区。对，对，对。但我会
coming twice maybe the second maybe you can you can come somewhere with me come to london with me so uh so what's going on what are we talking about today um oh am i supposed to have a topic because i'm not no no no i've got tons of topics you see kind of that that's what works about this relationship is that I can be lazy and just show up unprepared and you are just, you're just happy and eager to. Oh, yeah. I mean, I've literally got like 17 different episodes that we could chat about right now. Is it actually 17? No, I mean, I just made that number up.
来两次，也许第二次，你可以，你可以跟我去某个地方，跟我去伦敦。所以，嗯，怎么回事？我们今天在聊什么？嗯，我是不是应该有个主题，因为我没有？不，不，不，我有很多主题。你看，这种关系的运作方式是，我可以偷懒，毫无准备地出现，而你，你只是很高兴，渴望……哦，是的。我的意思是，我literally有大约 17 个不同的剧集可以现在聊。真的是 17 个吗？不，我的意思是，我只是瞎编的那个数字。
But like 15 of them are off topic, you know, probably like a good five of them have to do with combinatorial logic. Another three have to do with this new term I heard about called collection-oriented programming, which I submitted to give a talk at Closure Conj, which is in April. And anyways, we're not going to, these are things that we could talk about, but I'm not going to talk about just to, you know, if folks are interested, I'll leave a link to this paper, Parallel Block Delayed Sequences, which is about this sort of parallel algorithms model. But it mentions collection-oriented programming, which sent me on this deep dive like a couple weeks ago. What are you going to say? This is going to show you, dear listener, the difference between what Connor thinks about in his spare time and what I think about in my spare time. And you're going to have to air this because this is a call for help.
但大概有 15 个是题外话，你知道，可能大概有整整 5 个与组合逻辑有关。另外 3 个与我听到的一个叫面向集合编程的新术语有关，我提交了这个话题要在 Closure Conj 上演讲，该会议在四月举行。总之，我们不会……这些是我们可以谈论的事情，但我不会谈论它们，只是为了，你知道，如果大家感兴趣的话，我会留下这篇论文的链接，《并行块延迟序列》，这是关于这种并行算法模型的。但它提到了面向集合编程，这让我几周前开始深入研究。你要说什么？这会向你展示，亲爱的听众，康纳在闲暇时间想的东西和我在闲暇时间想的东西之间的区别。你得把这段播客放出来，因为这是在呼救。
Here it is. I need somebody who speaks Japanese who can make a phone call for me. All right. Thanks for that, Bryce. You're not going to ask why? Go ahead. Why? Because I need them to call this little restaurant
给你。我需要一个会说日语的人帮我打个电话。好了。谢谢你，布莱斯。你不会问为什么吗？说吧。为什么？因为我需要他们给那家小餐厅打电话
that I ate at in Kyoto because they had this amazing cheesecake. It was this little French restaurant. It's sort of an immediate problem because my girlfriend really liked it, and I want to make it for her birthday, which is coming up. So please, somebody reach out. I need some help here. Rest assured.
我在京都吃过饭的那家，因为他们有这个惊人的芝士蛋糕。那是一家法国小餐厅。这算是个燃眉之急，因为我女朋友真的很喜欢，我想给她做这个当生日蛋糕，她的生日快到了。所以拜托，请有人联系我。我这里需要一些帮助。放心吧。
I will fast forward your voice at 10x for most of that and just leave in like a couple words to give people the sense. But someone will DM you or, you know, post a comment on the ADSP Twitter, Twitter post with I speak Japanese, how may I be of service? I'm sure back to all my topics that we're not going to talk about. I mean, a whole other thing I've spent, I have this, I'm working up towards building a course on algorithms that at some point I'm going to create. And it's going to be, it's going to be based around a set of 10 problems. Um, some of which we've discussed like the maximum consecutive ones, that's, uh, the third or second problem. And these are problems that I just have spent a lot of time thinking about and, you know, like to think about them while I'm running. And I recently came across a problem called Max, Max gap. And we should actually throw it to a different episode. But there's like two different flavors of
我会把你的声音快进 10 倍来播放大部分内容，只保留几个词让大家有个概念。但会有人私信你，或者，你知道，在 ADSP 推特推文下发评论说“我会说日语，请问有什么可以效劳的？”我确信……回到我们不打算谈论的所有主题上。我的意思是，我还花了另一整件精力在做的事，我有一个，我正在筹备一门关于算法的课程，我迟早会创建它。它将是，它将围绕一组 10 个问题展开。嗯，其中一些我们已经讨论过了，比如最大连续 1 的个数，那是，呃，第三个或第二个问题。这些是我花了很多时间思考的问题，你知道的，比如在我跑步的时候思考它们。我最近偶然发现了一个问题，叫作最大，最大间距。我们其实应该把它放到另一期去讲。但这里面大概有两种不同的风格
this problem. And it's just been, it's been amazing. I'll leave a link in the description for folks that want to go. You can't just tell me that and not like now okay okay i'm talking about max gap i just i just don't want to i don't want to dedicate this whole episode maybe we'll dedicate this whole episode we'll keep the chit chat at the beginning in but so max gap it's given a list of integers determine the difference, the maximum difference between two adjacent elements. Okay, they're adjacent. If the list is sorted. So you could simplify the problem
这个问题。这简直太棒了。我会在描述中留下链接，供想去的人查看。你不能只告诉我这个，然后又不——好吧，好吧，我在说最大间距，我只是不想，我不想把整集都用来讲这个，也许我们会把整集都用来讲这个，我们会保留开始的闲聊，但是呢，最大间距，给定一个整数列表，确定两个相邻元素之间的差值，最大差值。好吧，它们是相邻的。如果列表是已排序的。所以你可以简化问题
and say, given a sorted list, what's the maximum difference between two adjacent elements? What is it, if it's not sorted, what is it supposed to give you? Well, I mean, so there, so I just simplified the problem. And in the more complicated problem, the steps are sort it first, and then...
然后说，给定一个已排序的列表，两个相邻元素之间的最大差值是多少？它是什么，如果它没有排序，它应该给你什么？嗯，我的意思是，所以，这里，所以我刚刚简化了问题。在更复杂的问题中，步骤是先对它进行排序，然后……
Okay, all right. So you want to just assume that we have a sorted list. Yeah, so I'm just simplifying. Like, the actual problem is given an arbitrarily, whatever, shuffled list of integers. If you sort it, what's the maximum difference between two adjacent elements? But honestly, clearly the first step of this if you sort it what's the maximum difference between two adjacent elements but honestly the clearly the first step of this problem is sorted why why is this tricky it's not it's not i'm just like so this problem itself especially like talk me through
好吧，好吧。所以你想假设我们有一个已排序的列表？是的，所以我只是在简化。比如，实际的问题是给定一个任意的、无论怎样的、被打乱的整数列表。如果你对它排序，两个相邻元素之间的最大差值是多少？但老实说，这个问题的显然第一步是，如果你对它排序，两个相邻元素之间的最大差值是多少？但老实说，这个问题的显然第一步是排序。为什么？为什么这很棘手？它不棘手，它不，我只是……所以这个问题本身，特别是，跟我聊聊
how you'd solve it and then i'll add a little extra in here. I guess I would just do it in... My first thought is like an inclusive scan. Oh, okay. My first reaction is, okay, we're looking to find the maximum of something. So we're doing a reduction. Anytime we're looking through a list of things and we're looking to find, you know, the greatest or the smallest or something like that, some sort of local minima or maxima or global minima and maxima, then it's reduction. So, but in this case, it's sort of a stenciled reduction. And so that's why I said inclusive scan. But inclusive scan doesn't actually make sense because we don't need all those partial sums.
你会怎么解决它，然后我会在这里加一点料。我想我会用……我的第一反应就像是一个包含性扫描。哦，好吧。我的第一反应是，好吧，我们在寻找某种东西的最大值。所以我们在做归约。每当我们遍历一个列表并试图找到，你知道的，最大值或最小值之类的时候，某种局部极小值或极大值，或全局极小值和极大值，那么它就是归约。所以，但在这种情况下，它是一种模板化的归约。这就是为什么我说包含性扫描。但包含性扫描其实没有意义，因为我们不需要所有那些部分和。
So I guess it's just like, it's just a reduction where it's like a zip reduce basically. It's how I would do it where the two input sequences that I would give to the reduction would be, one would be like from the zero element to the n minus one element, and the other one would be from the first element to the n element. And so if you create those two sub-sequences of the original sequence, and then you feed them into a zip, and then you do a reduction on that zipped view then you've you're doing a reduction on the pairs of adjacent elements um and then the reduction you just do you know um max and like if i miss something nope you are 100 correct this is fantastic and i'm actually it's a shame i'm almost positive we talked about this exact thing on a previous – not this exact problem, but something where this thing came up.
所以我想它就像是，它只是一个归约，基本上就像是一个 zip 归约。我是这么做的，我提供给归约的两个输入序列将是，一个是，从第 0 个元素到第 n 减 1 个元素，另一个是从第一个元素到第 n 个元素。所以如果你创建了原始序列的这两个子序列，然后你把它们输入到一个 zip 中，然后你在那个 zip 视图上做一个归约，那么你就在对相邻元素的对进行归约，然后归约你只需要做，你知道的，求 max，像这样。如果我漏掉了什么？不，你 100% 正确，这太棒了。而且实际上，真遗憾，我几乎可以肯定我们在之前的一期节目中讨论过这个确切的事情——不是这个确切的问题，而是某种出现过这个东西的事情。
We'll come back to it in a second because I'm being vague while I'm referring to thing. My first question I'm going to ask is what is the name of the algorithm where you do the zip to first to second last and then second to last and if you want a hint i can give you a hint because there's actually two correct answers to this question well isn't it isn't it one of the um the window ones the sliding ones yes that is not the name of it though yeah i don't know i don't know what the one is one is an algorithm from C++. Wait, hang on, hang on, hang on. I am the... No, no, no. I see your eyes shifting around, going to CPP reference.
我们一会儿再回来讨论它，因为我在指代事物时说得比较含糊。我要问的第一个问题是，当你把 zip 操作应用到第一个到倒数第二个，然后是第二个到最后一个时，这个算法叫什么名字？如果你想要提示，我可以给你一个提示，因为这个问题其实有两个正确答案。嗯，难道它不是那个，嗯，窗口算法中的一个吗？滑动窗口？是的，但那不是它的名字。嗯，我不知道，我不知道那个是什么。一个是来自 C++ 的算法。等等，等等，等等。我是……不，不，不。我看到你的眼神在游移，正看向 CPP 参考手册。
Yeah, I'm going to go look because I know how to find the answer because I am the chair of the C++ Library Evolution Group, and I'm pretty sure that this is the thing that was added under my tenure. So I should know this. I just don't remember the name. But I remember the paper. I remember the paper. I'm talking to you, listener.
对，我要去查一下，因为我知道怎么找到答案，因为我是 C++ 库演化小组的主席，而且我非常确定这是在我任期内添加的东西。所以我应该知道这个。我只是不记得名字了。但我记得那篇论文。我记得那篇论文。我在对你说话，听众朋友。
And there's a silver medal answer and a gold medal answer. The silver medal answer is from C++98. The gold medal answer is from C++23. And this is just the first step. so it doesn't include the reduction. It's just this. And in functional languages, this is called ziptail. So it's slide, right, is the one that we want for this 23 one? You can solve this with slide, but slide is a...
这里有一个银牌答案和一个金牌答案。银牌答案来自 C++98。金牌答案来自 C++23。这只是第一步。所以它不包括归约。仅仅是这个。在函数式语言中，这被称为 ziptail。所以它叫 slide，对吧，是我们想要的这个 23 版本的？你可以用 slide 来解决这个问题，但 slide 是一个……
Slide's not what you have in mind? No, it is not the exact version of what we want. Because slide, there's a C++23 ranges adapter that is very similar to slide, but slide returns you a range of ranges. There's a sibling algorithm to this that returns you a range of tuples and a specialization of that one that we want exactly for this. And we talked about it when we listed off all the different range adapters. However, there's also a sibling algorithm to this back from C++98.
Slide 不是你脑子里想的那个？不，它不是我们想要的精确版本。因为 slide，有一个 C++23 的 ranges 适配器非常类似于 slide，但是 slide 返回给你一个 range 的 range。有一个与此平行的算法，它返回给你一个 tuple 的 range，并且我们要找的正是那个的特化版本。当我们列出所有不同的 range 适配器时，我们谈论过它。然而，这还有一个来自 C++98 的平行算法。
We've added too many of them. Yep. That's why you got me, Bryce. I memorize all this stuff for fun. It makes me happy. See, there's this thing called Google that, you know, replaces you. I don't, I don't, I don't need Google because I mean, don't get me wrong. I've, I don't think about like the set algorithms very often, like asymmetric difference or
我们加了太多这种东西。没错。这就是为什么你找了我，布莱斯。我为了好玩背下所有这些东西。这让我很开心。看，有个东西叫谷歌，你知道，它能替代你。我，我，我不需要谷歌，因为，我的意思是，别误会我。我，我不常去想集合算法，比如非对称差集或者
et cetera, those ones. But you know, these ones are, these ones are fundamental. Okay. So you're saying it's like slide, but it gives you tuples. Yep. Um, interesting. Um, slide but it gives you tuples yeah um interesting um wow is it is it adjacent yes yeah and even more so i mean of course it's adjacent yeah adjacent so adjacent is basically identical to slide. Slide takes its window size as an argument, variable arguments, whereas adjacent takes its window size as a template argument.
等等，那些。但你知道，这些是，这些是基础。好吧。所以你是说它就像 slide，但它给你 tuples？Yep。嗯，有趣。嗯，slide 但它给你 tuples，对，嗯，有趣，嗯，哇，它是，它是 adjacent 吗？是的，而且更确切地说，当然是 adjacent，对吧，adjacent。所以 adjacent 基本上和 slide 相同。Slide 接受其窗口大小作为参数，可变参数，而 adjacent 接受其窗口大小作为模板参数。
But we even want something that's even more specific than adjacent. I mean, well, in this case, just want like uh adjacent transformed exactly because we are taking the i don't know what you're looking for there we're taking the difference so we're passing stood colon colon minus two yeah yeah oh so it's just adjacent transform than meduse. Oh, that's very elegant. And do you know what the C++98 is? Hang on, hang on, hang on. I want to pick a fight with you here, which is that I believe that my answer of slide, like slide and adjacent are more or less the same thing.
但我们甚至想要比 adjacent 更具体的东西。我的意思是，在这个情况下，只需要像，嗯，adjacent_transform，确实如此，因为我们正在取，我不知道你在那找什么，我们正在取差值，所以我们传递的是 std::minus 嘛。对，对。哦，所以它只是 adjacent_transform 然后是 reduce。哦，这太优雅了。你知道 C++98 的那个是什么吗？等等，等等，等等。我想在这里跟你争论一下，我认为我的回答 slide，就像 slide 和 adjacent 差不多是同一回事。
It's just, you know, one of them's, you're specifying the size that you're looking for at compile time versus runtime. Like I think I should get full credit for my answer slide. I will give you a fourth place not making it to the Olympics. You're on the what they call, you're an Olympic alternate. So you didn't get bronze, silver, or gold. The reason is, and specifically adjacent is not really the correct like the gold answer
只不过，你知道，其中一个是你在编译时而不是运行时指定你想要的大小。我觉得我的回答 slide 应该得满分。我给你评个第四名，没进奥运会那种。你属于他们所说的奥运替补。所以你没拿铜牌、银牌或金牌。原因在于，特别是 adjacent 并不是真正的正确答案，比如金牌答案
was adjacent transform and it's specifically because if you're using adjacent or slide spelling that out is way less elegant because in the slide example you're going to pass two to get a range of two a range of ranges where each inner range is two elements but then how are you going to destructure that and take the difference? Yeah, okay. You basically have to call like dot begin and dot end on those. And then even with the adjacent, you still have to unwrap the tuples with either a lambda that uses C++17 structure bindings
就是adjacent transform，具体原因是因为如果你用adjacent或者slide，显式写出来远不如它优雅。因为在slide的示例中，你需要传2来获取一个由2个元素组成的范围的范围，也就是每个内部范围有两个元素，但随后你该如何解构它并求差呢？是的，好吧。你基本上得在它们上面调用诸如dot begin和dot end之类的方法。即便用了adjacent，你仍然得解包元组，要么用一个使用C++17结构化绑定的lambda
or the std colon colon get angle zero, angle one. Whereas adjacent transform was specifically added in the case where and actually there's even one more specialization which if barry is listening to this episode our guest guest from last episode he's going to be going you're actually it's still not the most specific one because there's a view adapter called pairwise which is a specialization of adjacent transform where the size is two i'm not a huge fan of the pairwise name even though it has precedence in f sharp um i think a javascript library and then also the python more iter tool so there's a couple libraries in popular languages
或者std::get。而adjacent transform的添加，恰好是为了这种情况。实际上还有一个特化版本，如果Barry正在听这一集——也就是我们上一集的嘉宾——他大概会说：“实际上，它依然不是最特化的那个，因为有一个叫做pairwise的视图适配器，它是adjacent transform的特化，大小为2。”我其实不太喜欢pairwise这个名字，尽管它在F#中先于C++出现，嗯，我想还有一个JavaScript库，然后还有Python的more itertools，所以在一些流行语言中有好几个库
and f sharp has it as specifically this like adjacent i. I don't know that we have it in standard C++. C++ 23? Yes, we do. Well, then somebody needs to go update C++ Reference because adjacent. It's there. No, it's not. Which one? I see adjacent, but not pairwise.
而且F#明确把它叫做这种类似于adjacent的东西。我不知道我们标准C++里有没有。C++23？是的，我们有。那得有人去更新一下C++ Reference了，因为adjacent……它在那儿。不，不在。哪一个？我看到adjacent了，但没有pairwise。
It's there. You're not looking at the right place. Okay. Well, I'm looking at cppre okay well i'm looking at cpp reference dot com slash w slash cpp slash ranges which is where adjacent is oh no no it's it's on the page for uh adjacent view because i think it's just a um specialization of it yeah okay that makes sense no no it's not a specialization it's an alias specialization can't be under a different name it's an alias for adjacent exactly sorry boom you under a different name. It's an alias for adjacent to.
它在那儿。你看错地方了。好吧。嗯，我在看cppre——好吧，我在看cppreference.com/w/cpp/ranges，adjacent就在那上面。哦，不不不，它在“adjacent view”那个页面上，因为我觉得它只是个……特化。对，好吧，那就说得通了。不不不，它不是特化，它是别名。特化不能换个名字。它就是adjacent的别名，对，抱歉。轰！你换了个名字，它其实就是adjacent的别名。
Exactly. Sorry. Boom! You just got owned! It is true. 100% you get that. I am one of the most pedantic people you'll meet, and I'm using the wrong word there. It is an alias cost us nothing. It's like one line. It's like yada, yada, yada, pairwise equals adjacent to, where the yada, yada, yada is inline constexpr auto. Yeah, this is a very, very lightweight argument. This is not a strong opinion loosely held. This is like a weak opinion loosely held. I am not a big fan of it because it sort of falls into the same category of std accumulate and other algorithms coming with default binary operations.
没错。抱歉。轰！你刚刚被秒杀！确实如此。100%你会这么觉得。我是你见过的最迂腐的人之一，结果我在这里还用错了词。它是个别名，对我们来说没有任何成本。就像是一行代码。就像是yada yada yada，pairwise等于adjacent到，其中yada yada yada是inline constexpr auto。是的，这是一个非常非常轻量的论点。这不是那种“持有浅薄之见的强烈观点”，这是一个“持有浅薄之见的弱观点”。我不太喜欢它，因为它有点落入类似于std accumulate和其他带有默认二元操作的算法的同一种分类里。
Pairwise is one extra thing for people to learn. And I don't think what it saves us, it saves us two chevrons and actually the number two. So it's three characters that it saves us. And I actually think that adjacent transform is more meaningful to the C++ program when you already have adjacent, adjacent difference, adjacent find. Yeah, I actually completely agree with you that I think it actually reduces clarity. Yeah. I've made these, I had that lightning talk called algorithm selection, where I start with mismatch as the most general algorithm and then show that stood equal and stood any of and stood adjacent find. All these algorithms are quote unquote specializations that can be spelled with stood mismatch. And this is one of these, like I could do the same thing now for adjacent, adjacent transform and pairwise transform and pairwise, sorry, adjacent pairwise, adjacent transform and pairwise transform and pairwise and sorry, adjacent
对人们来说，Pairwise是又一个需要学习的东西。我不认为它给我们节省了什么，它只给我们省了两个尖括号，以及数字2。所以它只帮我们省了三个字符。而且我实际上认为，对于C++程序员来说，当你已经有了adjacent、adjacent difference、adjacent find之后，adjacent transform会更有意义。是的，我其实完全同意你的看法，我觉得它实际上降低了清晰度。是的。我做过这些，我曾经做过一个名为“算法选择”的闪电演讲，我在演讲中以mismatch作为最通用的算法开头，然后展示了std equal、std any of和std adjacent find。所有这些算法都是所谓的“特化”，其实完全可以用std mismatch来拼写。现在我可以对adjacent、adjacent transform和pairwise transform以及pairwise——抱歉，adjacent
pairwise, adjacent transform and pairwise transform. And I just think that like, I think back when I was attending the ranges monthly meetings, I voted like weekly against adding this, but other folks were a big fan. And my biggest thing is that like, is there precedence for it? And in other languages, there is precedence for it. And I couldn't find like multiple names. And of the names that you might want to give this to, I guess it's decent. But I just would, I would rather have nothing there the same way I would rather have like
pairwise、adjacent transform和pairwise transform做同样的事情。我只是觉得，回想我参加C++ ranges月度会议的时候，我曾投票反对添加这个，但其他人非常喜欢。我最大的疑虑是：它有先例吗？在其他语言中，确实有先例。而且我找不到多个名字。在你可以给它取的那些名字里，它大概还算得过去。但我宁愿那里什么都没有，就像我宁愿……
our left fold accumulate, not take a default operation. Yeah. And it's also the same thing as keys and values. I always forget about this, is that there is a view adapter called elements, which gives you the ability if you're looping over tuples, typically this is like two tuples that represent like a key value pair. You can use elements 0, 1, 2, 3, 4 to get access to the nth element from a tuple. And we have, once again, two aliases, keys for element 0 and values for elements 1, which I just think is like pretty undesirable in many cases where what you have is not like
我们的左折叠accumulate不采用默认操作一样。是的。这也是keys和values的问题。我老是忘掉这个，就是有一个叫做elements的视图适配器，如果你在遍历元组，通常这就像是代表键值对的双元素元组，它能让你访问元组中的第n个元素。我们可以使用elements 0、1、2、3、4来访问。我们再次拥有了两个别名：用keys代表element 0，用values代表elements 1。我觉得在许多情况下这相当不可取，因为你拥有的并非
a key value pair. I could technically have like a four tuple that represents like a four dimensional data point for some, I don't know, chemistry or space thing where it's just like a dimension of some four point thing. And I could use values to get the second one, like at index one, just because it happens to be an alias for elements one. And in cases where you have key value pairs, it's all right. But it just, yeah yeah these things i would rather have like the bare like core sort of fundamental algorithms and then in certain cases like any of and all of and none of those provide a lot more readability but also more importantly if you want keys values
键值对。我技术上可以拥有一个四元组，代表某种化学或太空问题中的四维数据点，它只是某个四维事物的一个维度。我可以用values来获取第二个元素，也就是索引为1的元素，仅仅因为它碰巧是elements 1的别名。在你处理键值对的情况下，这还可以。但就是……是的，是的，我宁愿拥有那种最核心、最基础的算法，然后在某些特定情况下，比如any of、all of和none of，它们能提供更好的可读性。但更重要的是，如果你想要keys、values
or pairwise it's like one line that you can add to your program like if you if it like it's very easy for you to add that yourself. So yeah. Although I would sort of say that's kind of like it's obfuscating code that like the average C++ developer that really goes
或者pairwise，这就好比你可以在程序里添加的一行代码——如果你需要的话，你自己加起来非常容易。所以，是的。尽管我可以说，这有点像是在混淆代码，让那些真正去研究
and understands these views adapters. If they then see something, they're going to have to go F12 on it, which isn't a ton of work. But anyways, like I said, this is a weak opinion, loosely held. Like it's something that I'm against, but also, it doesn't break my heart that it's there.
并理解这些视图适配器的普通C++开发者……如果他们随后看到了某种东西，他们就必须对它按F12，这虽然不算太大的工作量。但无论如何，就像我说的，这是一个持保留态度的弱观点。我虽然反对它，但它存在我也不会心碎。
I will choose to write adjacent transform bracket to angle bracket and be done with it. So just playing devil's advocate there for a minute. Because the associative containers that have a key value, you know, separations like maps, basically, because the maps store things as a stood pair of key value. to work with these the map containers and um uh and ranges if you didn't have the the helpful aliases like essentially what i'm saying what i'm arguing is that the the existence of the map containers and their design using uh giving you like when you ask for like a view of them um uh you're going to get a sequence of key value pairs um like because of that um and like correct me if i'm wrong but there's no way to like there's like no method on map where i can say like just give me a sequence of the keys is there not that i have used right so i i the alternative, if we didn't want, like, instead of having the alias for keys, I think we could have added a method to map and unordered map and multi-maps that returned you a range that was the keys and the values, and it would just do elements 0 and 1.
我会选择写adjacent transform括号到尖括号，然后就完事了。所以，我在这里稍微扮演一下反方辩护人。因为那些有键值对的关联容器，你知道的，比如map之类的分离，基本上是因为map把东西存储为std pair的键值对。为了配合这些map容器以及……嗯……ranges，如果你没有那些有帮助的别名——基本上我想说的是，我的论点是，map容器的存在以及它们的设计，通过给予你……当你请求它们的某个view时……你会得到一个键值对序列……正因为如此……而且如果我没记错的话，纠正我如果我错了，map上有没有什么方法能让我说“只给我一个键的序列，不要值”？没有我用过的，对吧。所以，如果我不想要……
I think that would have been a fine alternative to do, although I am loathe to add more member functions to containers. And I think generally in C++ library design, for something that's like a separate concern, like algorithms, we tend to like to have the algorithms be um uh separate uh free functions that operate on generic things not uh things that are um members of uh of our data structures um but i think in this case having that little helper would have been fine and useful and then we wouldn't have had to have this you know stood ranges element stood ranges keys and stood or i guess it's stood views keys and stood views values yeah i mean i haven't spent a ton of time thinking about it but like
如果不是为keys设置别名，我想我们可以给map、unordered map和multi-maps添加一个方法，返回一个由键和值组成的range，它内部其实就是调用elements 0和1。我认为这会是一个很好的替代方案，尽管我很厌恶给容器添加更多的成员函数。而且我认为通常在C++库设计中，对于像算法这样独立的事情，我们往往倾向于让算法成为独立的自由函数，去操作通用的东西，而不是作为我们的数据结构的成员函数。但我认为在这种情况下，拥有那个小小的辅助函数会很好也很实用，这样我们就不用搞出这些……你知道的，std ranges element、std ranges keys和std——或者说应该是std views keys和std views values。是的，我的意思是，我没有花太多时间去思考它，但……
i think in the case where you're turning a associative container with keys and values into a range, and then if we didn't have keys and values, the aliases, then you'd have to use elements. In that case, you're losing, and you probably do want to use the aliases, keys, and values. But I think I would, off the top of my head, like, I would prefer, because in the case where you're not dealing with keys and values in some kind of associative container, it is adding semantic context where it's like not useful. And in fact, it's harmful probably. And probably something like first and second, even though in the associative container, when you have keys and values, that's still less helpful than keys and values. When you use first and second on any other context, it's more helpful. And so if we were going to add aliases, I would argue for something like that. But anyways, we're totally getting away from max gap though. So, and also, do you know what the, we still haven't said the silver answer to the C++ 98.
我认为，如果你把一个带有键和值的关联容器变成一个range，而我们又没有keys和values这两个别名，那你大概就得用elements了。那样的话，你就会失去……你可能确实想要使用keys和values这两个别名。但我凭直觉会更倾向于……因为在你不涉及某种关联容器的键和值的情况下，它添加的语义上下文不仅没用，而且可能有害。可能类似于first和second，尽管在关联容器中，当你拥有键和值时，这仍然不如keys and values有用。当你在任何其他上下文中使用first和second时，它会更有用。所以如果要添加别名，我会主张用那种类型的。不过无论如何，我们已经完全偏离最大间距（max gap）的话题了。那么，还有，你知道吗……我们还没说出C++ 98的那个绝妙答案。
No, I was going to ask about that. Yeah, I don't know. Tell me. It's the second or first worst named algorithm in C++, in my opinion, which is adjacent difference. Oh, yeah, yeah. Adjacent difference would make sense, yes. Which is basically adjacent transform with a bunch of properties that suck because it's encoded the default std minus operation into the name of the algorithm, which I've mentioned on many different places. But so, yes, you do your adjacent transform, and then you basically just do a maximum reduction. And this is problem six of my 10 problems.
不，我正要问这个呢。是的，我不知道。告诉我。依我之见，它是C++中第二或第一难听名字的算法，也就是adjacent difference。哦，对，对。Adjacent difference说得通，是的。它基本上就是adjacent transform，带有一堆糟糕的特性，因为它把默认的std minus操作编码到了算法的名字里，我已经在很多不同地方提到了这一点。所以，是的，你做你的adjacent transform，然后基本上再做一个最大值规约（maximum reduction）。这就是我那10个问题中的第6个问题。
I used to have five, and then I recently added two in the last week. You shouldn't ask me any algorithm problems that are solved by reduce, because you know that my first go-to thing for any problem that you give me is, can I solve this by a reduction? Well, that was the thing, though, is if we go back to your original answer, what was my response?
我以前有5个，然后最近一周又加了2个。你可别问我任何能通过reduce解决的算法问题，因为你知道我拿到任何问题的第一反应都是：“我能不能通过规约来解决它？”好吧，关键就在于，如果我们回到你最初的答案，我的回应是什么？
100% correct. A reduction where you're zipping together, you're doing the zip tail trick, the tail from functional languages, meaning you're zipping sort of your original sequence with the tail of it, which is dropping the first element. That's the, that is like semantically the exact thing we're trying to do here. The, then like the follow-up question was like, how do you spell that using adapters? Which you don't lose points for not getting the right names of that stuff. But this is where it gets interesting because problem seven, like that problem itself is
100%正确。这是一种规约，你把它们组合（zip）在一起，你正在做“zip tail”的把戏，也就是函数式语言中的tail（尾部），意思是你把原始序列和它的尾部（去掉了第一个元素）进行组合。那就是……在语义上，这正是我试图在这里做的事情。然后……接下来的问题是：“你如何用适配器来拼写它？”如果你没猜对那些东西的名字，也不会被扣分。但有趣的地方就在这里，因为第7个问题……那个问题本身……
not like, it's, it's nice to know that, oh, there's a nice function in C++ 23 ranges now where you can go adjacent transform. And then currently right now without the pipeline operator, you know, we're not able to pipe that to a max reduction. So you have to pass it to std colon colon ranges, colon colon max, which we might talk about in the next episode. I'm not sure if you saw this tweet that I had, which has become like the third most liked and second most retweeted. And it's caused a ton of opinions having to do with C++26 pipeline operator. But where I'm going with this is there is a problem number seven,
倒也不是……知道这一点挺好的，哦，C++ 23 ranges里现在有一个很棒的函数，你可以用adjacent transform。然后目前在没有管道操作符（pipeline operator）的情况下，你知道的，我们无法把它管道传输给max reduction。所以你必须把它传给std::ranges::max，我们可能在下一集里讨论这个。我不知道你有没有看到我发的那个推文，它已经变成了点赞数第三高、转发数第二高的推文。它引发了大量关于C++ 26管道操作符的观点。但我说到这儿的意思是，有一个第7个问题，
which is a modified version of this problem, which I think is just incredibly intellectually stimulating. And I've spent so much time thinking about it and how to spell this in different languages. Same problem. We'll assume that we already have a sorted list of numbers. And the question is now not what is the maximum of adjacent values,
它是这个问题的修改版，我认为它在智力上极其具有启发性。我花了很多时间思考它，以及如何在不同的语言中拼写它。同样的问题。我们假设我们已经有了一个排好序的数字列表。现在的问题不是相邻值的最大值是什么，
difference between adjacent values, but what is the count of the maximum difference between adjacent values? And this, this is where things get interesting. So wait, so wait, you want the, you want to know how many times that maximum gap occurs. Yes. And I realized probably I should have done this 20 minutes ago. Also, we might be bleeding in. This might be part two now of this episode.
相邻值之间的差值是什么，而是相邻值之间的最大差值出现了多少次？这里，这里事情就变得有趣了。等等，所以……等等，你想知道那个最大间距出现了多少次。是的。我意识到我大概20分钟前就该这么做了。另外，我们可能会串台。这现在可能是这一集的第二部分了。
I probably should have given an example. So for instance, for the first problem, if we had the numbers 1, 3, 5, and 10, the differences are 2, 2, and 5. So the answer to that question is 5. But for the second problem, the answer would be 1 because there is 1, 5. However, if the sequence was 1, 3, 5, 10, 15, 20, our differences are then 2, 2, 5, 5, 5. And so then you want the count of the number of 5s, whatever the maximum difference is. In this case, it would be 3. And it's only a slightly different problem,
我大概应该举个例子。比如，对于第一个问题，如果我们有数字1、3、5和10，差值是2、2和5。所以这个问题的答案是5。但对于第二个问题，答案将是1，因为只有一个5。然而，如果序列是1、3、5、10、15、20，我们的差值就是2、2、5、5、5。那么你想要的是数字5出现的次数，也就是最大差值出现的次数。在这个例子中，答案将是3。这只是一个稍微不同的问题，
but the implications on how you solve this, I think are interesting. Tune in next week to hear part two of this two-part episode where we solve max gap count. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你如何解决它的含义，我认为这很有趣。请收听下周的节目，聆听这个两集连载的第二部分，我们将在这里解决最大间距计数（max gap count）问题。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。